[Music]
six years after its release skyrim still
manages to be relevant between the 2016
remaster the upcoming VR version and now
a switch port it's hard to forget about
the Elder Scrolls 5 and that's a
testament to how absorbing an RPG it is
with the addition of instant portability
on switch and the high quality of the
port itself it's now even harder to put
down Skyrim is one of the best switch
ports currently available though it's
not too surprising considering the
game's age it runs smoothly with a
rock-solid framerate in both smaller
spaces and in the overworld text can be
a little small when playing handheld
though it still plays as well as it does
docked him with a pro controller motion
controls are all optional as well
wagging a joy Conn will swing a sword
and moving your controller of choice
will aim your bow Skyrim does retain the
expected glitches fans have come to love
though including Bazaar and PC pathing
problems in our 10 hours testing the
game we didn't find any new bugs so it's
just the silly charming weirdness you
might remember in Whiterun the main
edition on switch is amiibo
compatibility which is there only if you
really want to try it
amiibo uses nested in the magic menu
under powers and you have to cast it the
way you would any other power before
tapping an ebow to the NFC reader like
in breath of the wild using amiibo isn't
a guarantee of good loot in this case
Zelda amiibo give you a chance to get
links spread the wild tunic the Master
Sword and the Hylian Shield that you
might get a chest filled with arrows or
an assortment of meats instead you can
use each amiibo once per day but we were
able to get all the cool gear in one day
using a few Zelda amiibo around the
office as a bonus the gear actually was
better than any of the early game armor
and weapons all other amiibo will get
you a basic loot chest the quality of
the port decides Skyrim has certainly
aged since it first released in 2011 the
off maligned sword and shield combat has
fared the most poorly of course since it
never felt great two columns leaving the
sword around in the first place there's
also no mod support currently so if
you're used to quality of life mods it
can be weird to go back to regular old
Skyrim even if you still find its quirks
charming
but the original version of Skyrim is
still an immense engrossing RPG and the
quality number and variety of its quests
makes it easy to become as lost in its
world as ever
there's so much to do in Skyrim that
it's likely you haven't done it all yet
and because it's now portable you can
pick up and play for shorter verse that
can easily turn into hours with the
addition of Zelda themed gear that's
actually useful and the fact that you
can play anywhere the switch version of
Skyrim is a great opportunity to revisit
a much-loved RPG for more on Skyrim you
can check out our impressions of the
special edition and our original review
on GameSpot
[Music]